stop telling kids to go on your patreon
and chat to you privately without their
parents knowing
and uploaded it on Tick Tock without my
hijab now this is a very important story
of a Muslim woman
exposing a person who identifies as a I
do not identify as either a man or a
woman logical sex is fake yes we all
know that gender roles are fake but
that's not the main issue here it's her
courageous attempt to protect the little
ones to protect the children hi kids
hey kids I want to talk to the kids hi
kids
hey kids so yeah there's a lot of videos
of them addressing kids now the main
video I want to talk about your parents
screwed up
it's okay to say so that's why I made a
patreon so you want to talk to kids
whose parents have screwed up why why
you want to talk to these particular
kids why that's why I made a patreon so
that we could talk about it so we could
connect in a way that has more privacy
so that we could talk to each other in a
way that's a more open and stuff that we
wouldn't share like in the comments of a
video like this
I think you're worthy and because of
that she's facing some backlash let's
have a look I want you to give a quick
update on what's going on with Jeffrey
Marsh I know I said that I'm going to
stay out of it you really should have
stayed out of it but you didn't and so
here we are most of you know that there
is a problematic creator with seven
million followers being super
transphobic right now this person right
here I only talked about their behavior
and I became transphobic what and then
you have this is just a quick example of
some of the response and I cannot
believe people are actually defending
this imagine if right after 9 11 we all
stitched your videos to make it look
like you were sympathetic to Al-Qaeda if
we did that you would call us
islamophobic and you'd be right you can
even see here that she brought forward
the definition the red flags of
predatory grooming Behavior this is
Jeffrey Marsh's patreon you talk about
this topic with kids now here are just
some of the signs of grooming literally
one of the first ones gaining access and
isolating the victim
asking them privately to go on patreon
and what does this say is you can see
here gaining access and isolating the
victim abusers will attempt to
physically or emotionally separate a
victim from those protecting them and
often seek out positions in which they
have contact with minors
that's why I made a patreon so that we
could talk about it so
it's an act in a way that has more
privacy
and I wanted to spend more
connected time with you two trust
development keeping secrets abusers
attempt to gain Trust of a potential
victim who gives attention-sharing
secrets and other means to make them
feel that they have caring that they
have a caring relationship and train
them to keep their relationship a secret
Now isn't this a red flag isn't this
what this individual is doing I will
tell you about going no contacts so
you've decided to go no contact
[Music]
isolating the parents keeping the secret
that time of year again when you start
thinking about going no contact you're
going to love it the bloody icing on the
bloody cake I coach a lot of people
one-on-one who want to go no contact
with their parents if you need a family
you can come hang out with me I love you
very much if you do not have a family
that loves you I'm going to be your
family your parents screwed up
it's okay to say so
talking about sexual behaviors with
children it's
okay and are you allowed to talk about
that on patreon is this not the
quintessential example of someone who
fits this description if you need a
family
you can come hang out with me and all
she did was expose this first ones
gaining access and isolating the victim
asking them privately to go on patreon
so then they went after her oh I just
got an email they know where I live they
have got my daughter's details on the
email they've given the school details
and everything yeah my daughters are
involved now in this as some of you
might know that my car was damaged in
this whole thing I'm done I don't want
to do anything
I'm not going to talk about Jeffrey
Marsh I've deleted everything like some
of you have found old pictures of me
but
and uploaded it on Tick Tock without my
hijab while the mainstream media machine
is still quiet on this the question is
where are the experts The Grooming
experts the doctors academics scientists
a panel a psychologist psychiatrists to
go ahead and to look into this person's
Behavior to see if it fits the
description they're analyzing this as
they do and some person identifies as
being a Muslim and does something
outside the folds of Islam and commit
some crime some act that totally Muslims
condemn so they bring on these panels of
experts we're the panel of experts here
to discuss this to see if this person
actually fits this criteria it's not
happening where's the Uproar all she was
trying to do was to protect the little
ones to protect the children and all
we're doing is practicing our religious
freedom and our freedom of speech and
before I close I want to bring to your
attention that the verbatim word of God
Almighty the Quran where shaytan is
being quote here as saying in chapter 4
verse 119 and this is shaytan being
quoted and I will mislead them this is a
promise he's making and I will entice
them and I will prompt them to Slit the
ears of cattle and I will prompt them to
alter the creation of God and then God
Almighty Allah is saying whoever takes
Satan shaytan as a lord instead of God
has surely suffered a profound loss
and we can see this happening we can see
them trying to change the creation of
God we can see them altering the things
the beautiful way that God Almighty
Allah has created the human being they
are trying to change this and we have a
clear verse in the verbat of word of God
Almighty Allah because what's happening
is a liberty attempt to confuse people
uh to confuse the children and that's
what happened when people are left with
without guidance they're left to follow
their desires and then all Havoc is
raining loose on the land but look at
this clear verse in the Quran when
you're upon clear guidance like what's
said here in chapter 41 verse 13 God
Almighty is addressing you all people he
says oh Humanity oh mankind o people
indeed I have created you this is God
Almighty look you have to understand
this is the creator of the heavens and
the Earth he's greater than you greater
than your desires and he is letting us
know and we're practicing our religious
freedom and this is in the Quran Allah
is saying God Almighty Allah saying that
I have created you from a male and a
female period
is done there are only two genders this
is what God Almighty Allah is saying in
the Quran this is what Christians
understand this is what Jews understand
this is what seeks and people of other
religions and people of science people
understand these things it's I I just
cannot understand how we've gotten here
but Muslims do understand because
there's an enemy to humanity and this is
the devil this is shaytan and the forces
of evil who are trying to corrupt the
minds of the humans to desensitize them
to confuse them to accept these kind of
things and we have to go ahead as a
community now this is the call to action
Community leader sheikhs academics
people of Consciousness at conferences
at your mjas at the masjids need to
start talking about this more you need
to start talking to your children this
is coming to your door you don't want
this hap happening now take this
into consideration this is a woman's
bathroom you don't want this happening
and you're caught off guard to have a
look
how can you tell me I'm not a
transgender no you're not well tell me
I'm not a transgender transgender
yeah so don't be like a ostrich with his
head in the sand
naive we have to be people of principle
holding to our values you have many
Muslims who have protested these things
and people have stepped back pull these
things from curriculums these books that
were out there and then people like this
the only solution at the end of the day
is a complete adherence that's
submission to the Creator that heavens
and earth this is all found in Islam so
we cannot as much as we had poured these
things as much as we're against us and
like the sister peacefully brought these
things to the attention of people this
grooming behavior that fit the
description red flag and she was facing
some backlash that's what's going to
happen
but you have to be courageous you have
to be brave at the end of the day we
want good for all of humanity so even
this individual and individuals out
there like this the solution for them
also because we cannot restrict the
mercy of God Almighty Allah we cannot
their only solution is also to turn away
from following the shaytan from turn
away from following their desires and
come to the mercy of Allah come to the
mercy of Islam go ahead and ask for the
guidance Guide Me Guide Me Guide Me and
you will see that so many
Allah's Mercy is encompassing but if a
person continues going down this route
and following the shaytan then they will
end up suffering of in this life they
will never find peace because they're
not living purpose they were always they
will always have that void in their
heart and when they die the gates of
paradise will be closed the Gates of
Hell Fire will be awaiting people like
this so let us not be people who end up
causing our own oppression we oppress
our souls we oppress ourselves we invite
Humanity to go ahead and accept this
free gift this free gift that will give
you when you go to the deanshow.com a
free copy of the Quran and we invite you
to look into Islam because Islam doesn't
Bend for none of these satanic games
these delusions
shaytans way of misguiding people no if
you want to be on guidance if you want
to be away from being misled call on the
Creator the heavens and the Earth ask
him and then because I want to end with
this this beautiful statement that God
Almighty Allah is saying all my slaves
are misguided unless I guide them
so ask me of my guidance that's all you
got to do his love is there his Mercy is
there you have to put your desires on
hold and say there's one that's greater
than this and he will help you to get
out of this confusion this misguidance
so ask for the guidance pick up this
free gift and like I said we do this out
of the love for Humanity so go ahead but
we also have to protect ourselves we
have to protect our children and we have
to speak the truth
practice our religious freedom and our
right to freedom of speech thank you
very much may God Almighty Allah bless
you guys for tuning in
go ahead and share this and get this out
like the video so more people can
benefit from this and we'll see you next
time until then peace be with you
assalamu alaikum what I love about this
project is that the whole project is
that one the whole project is that that
we train Muslims on how to give dawa
those who have accepted Islam teaching
them to be confident in dawah as Eddie
was walking me through the facility that
we're at right now he was showing me
that he has a vision of having an
Islamic school here for younger children
to come and learn their theme the goal
is to have a place where young Muslims
can come and roll the Jiu Jitsu Place
having an opportunity a soup kitchen
where people can come and you know
benefit from the generosity of the
Muslims the neighbors around here are
giving them an opportunity to benefit
from the Muslim Physicians and the
services that they have to offer this is
more than just a Masjid that's being
built with the hard work of Eddie and
the team that's with him you know one
thing I'll say that I saw here is that
Eddie is taking this Amana of the people
very seriously
the money that's being contributed to
this project is not being wasted
so this is a project that's led by the
ummah and it's for the ummah so I
encourage everyone here that can hear us
that can see it this beautiful project
that we're looking at has the potential
to be a beacon of light for the ummah
join us in this project inshallah so we
can establish the beautiful Dean Center